who is one person you hope reads this
book you I hope you read this book I
hope you've been watching this or listen
to this or hearing this you heard
something in there that makes you feel
like yeah he's talking to me that you're
not playing big enough that you could be
doing a lot more with your life that
you're not satisfied with the people in
your life what you've accomplished what
you think you could do I hope you read
this book I hope you read it I hope you
think about it i hope you apply the
lessons and i hope you write to me i
hope you write to me and tell me what
you think if you have questions let me
know but I hope you apply it I hope you
have the courage to apply it because a
lot of this what it's going to do is
shine a light I like them I've got like
the Sun on me here a shining light on me
as I'm saying it it's going to shine a
light on a lot of things in life that
you're not doing well that and that you
know but you may not be admitting to
yourself and it's going to give you the
steps and what to do to get through it
but are you gonna have the courage to go
and actually do it and so I really
encourage you not to just read another
book because you've read a thousand
books and maybe you've highlighted the
books but I want to actually take some
action on the book followed the
exercises just trust that it works and
let me show you some results because you
don't get results by just reading you
could be the smartest person in the room
but you're not going to get anywhere to
you actually take some action you'll see
people who are way less smart than you
who have waived fewer resources in you
who you know shouldn't be the ones
making it but they do because they did
something about it just having the idea
for a great product or service isn't
enough just having the idea to want to
change something in your life isn't
enough you got to actually take some
steps and so I hope you read it and more
than that I hope you apply some of the
lessons and then let me know how it's
going